a congenital diaphragmatic hernia is a
birth defect in which an abnormal
opening in a baby's diaphragm allows
abdominal organs to move into the chest
the diaphragm is a large dome shaped
sheet of muscle that separates the chest
from the abdomen when the baby breathes
in the diaphragm and outer rib muscles
contract expanding the chest cavity this
expansion lowers the air pressure inside
the chest creating a pressure change
that causes air to rush into the lungs
when the baby breathes out the diaphragm
relaxes and the inner rib muscles
contract reducing the size of the chest
cavity this reduced size increases the
air pressure inside the chest forcing
air out of the lungs
for unknown reasons the diaphragm in
some babies doesn't develop completely
before birth resulting in an opening
between the chest and abdomen the most
common location for this opening is on
the left side of the diaphragm near the
back
the baby's abdominal organs can push
through or herniate through this opening
in the diaphragm and compress the lungs
as a result the lungs do not develop
fully causing the baby to have
significant trouble breathing right
after birth
before the operation the baby will be
given general anesthesia to put him or
her to sleep for the entire operation a
breathing tube inserted soon after birth
through the nose or mouth and down the
throat will continue to help the baby
breathe during the operation
usually the surgeon will make an
incision under the ribs on the left side
next the surgeon will carefully move the
abdominal organs from the chest back to
their normal place in the abdomen if the
hole in the diaphragm is small it will
be closed with sutures alone
if the hole is too large or there isn't
enough muscle to close it a patch will
be sewn over it
finally the incision will be closed with
dissolvable sutures or closure tape
dressing
after the operation the baby will be
taken to the neonatal intensive care
unit for monitoring a mechanical
ventilator machine will help the baby
breathe for a few days or several weeks
pain medication will be given the baby
may continue to receive antibiotics
through the IV the hospital stay may
last for weeks or months depending on
the size and condition of the baby's
lungs if a patch was used the baby's
growth will need close monitoring
because the patch doesn't grow and may
start to pull away from the hole